-"Elle avait des bagues
à chaque doigt,
"des tas de bracelets
autour des poignets.
"Et puis elle chantait avec
une voix, qui, sitôt, m'enjôla.
"Elle avait des yeux,
des yeux d'opale
"qui fascinaient,
qui me fascinaient.
"Y avait l'ovale de son visage pâle
de femme fatale qui me fut fatal.
"De femme fatale qui me fut fatal.
"On s'est connu, on s'est reconnu.
"On s'est perdu de vue,
on s'est reperdu de vue.
"On s'est retrouvé,
on s'est réchauffé,
"puis on s'est séparé.
"Chacun pour soi est reparti
dans le tourbillon de la vie.
"Je l'ai revue un soir,
aïe, aïe, aïe !
"Ca fait déjà un fameux bail,
ça fait déjà un fameux bail.
"Au son des banjos
je l'ai reconnue.
"Ce curieux sourire
qui m'avait tant plu.
"Sa voix si fatale, son beau visage
pâle m'émurent plus que jamais.
"Je me suis soûlé en l'écoutant,
l'alcool fait oublier le temps.
"Je me suis réveillé en sentant,
des baisers sur mon front brûlant.
"Des baisers sur mon front brûlant.
"On s'est connu,
on s'est reconnu.
"On s'est perdu de vue,
on s'est reperdue de vue.
"On s'est retrouvé,
on s'est réchauffé,
"puis on s'est séparé.
"Chacun pour soi est reparti
dans le tourbillon de la vie.
"Je l'ai revue un soir ah, là là !
"Elle est retombée dans mes bras.
Elle est retombée dans mes bras.
"Quand on s'est connu,
quand on s'est reconnu.
"Pourquoi se perdre de vue,
se reperdre de vue ?
"Quand on s'est retrouvé,
quand on s'est réchauffé.
"Pourquoi se séparer ?
Alors tous deux on est repartis
"dans le tourbillon de la vie.
"On a continué à tourner
tous les deux enlacés.
"Tous les deux enlacés.
"Tous les deux enlacés."